[Music]
all right so it definitely feels like we
get these headlines like every couple
months but this latest round this
version feels pretty firm like apple is
going to make a USBC iPhone a USBC
iPhone is finally confirmed except
is it actually like this I've I've had
to resist the urge to make a video about
this first as long as this has been
talked about for months and months but
now there's actually something concrete
to talk about so let's address it so
it's been brewing for a while but the
background info is at the European Union
has passed legislation requiring all
phones and gadgets sold in the EU to
have a USBC Port it standardizes one
port across everything which includes of
course the iPhone which is currently not
USBC and this passed with flying covers
by the way 602 to 13. so then this past
week Joanna stern of the Wall Street
Journal was talking to some apple people
on stage about it she had apples Craig
federigi and Greg jaws and she asked
them about this ruling and Jaws gives
this you know pretty winding long-winded
answer about how the government
shouldn't be making these types of rules
and creates a lot of E-Waste potentially
but then eventually ends with you know
we don't want to but we'll comply
obviously we'll have to comply we have
no choice as as we do around the world
to comply to a local laws and boom of
course cue the headlines Apple confirms
the iPhone is getting USBC Apple says
iPhones will finally get usb-c ports
Apple confirms iPhones will get USB
type-c charging but
he didn't actually say that like again
let's keep in mind let's remember these
are very well media trained Apple
Executives doing a public interview they
are being very careful with their words
they specifically said they will comply
not that they will make a USBC iPhone
and there is a big difference so you can
actually pull up and read the document
with the exact law that's been passed
that they're all referring to
data.consilium.europa.eu I'll link it
below the like button if you want to
check it out for yourself it's very long
but on page 27 it gets into the exact
details of what it's mandating as far as
charging so to save you the time it
basically says for these categories here
including smartphones if a device is
capable of being charged via wired
charging it shall have a USBC port and
be able to be charged by a USBC cable
and the press release from the European
Parliament says that this will be in
effect by the end of the calendar year
2024 and
I'm with dave2d on this one apple never
specifically said that they will make a
USBC iPhone they would never say that
but I also don't think they ever will
see first of all when they switch to
lightning on that iPhone 5 back in the
day it was genuinely an innovation like
it was a much smaller Port which let
them push plenty of power and data for
the time and that opened up way more
room inside the phone than the outgoing
ancient 30 pin could allow so yes people
were mad for a few months about having
to get a new charging cable sure but
pretty quickly everyone sort of just
adopted and accepted lightning for the
iPhone and then Apple made What's called
the made for iPhone program or mfi which
basically means they get a cut of every
certified lightning accessory that
anyone ever sells so you want to make a
lightning accessory that plugs into the
iPhone and have it be taken seriously at
all well you'll need to get it certified
and then it's certified mfi made for
iPhone and that'll be 10 off the top of
every unit straight to Apple thank you
very much like just this mfi program has
made Apple millions and millions of
dollars over the years thanks to the
lightning Port but now it's 2022. it's
been almost a decade and lightning is
kind of an old outdated port at this
point we've moved on we've gotten much
better charging speeds and data speeds
and so lightning kind of sucks now so
Apple has been working towards their
next jump but their next jump wasn't
planned to be USB type-c their next jump
was planned to be to no port at all yeah
that's correct they've been moving
towards removing the port from the
iPhone entirely I have a whole video
about this I highly recommend watching
it after this one I'll make it the first
link below but yes Apple would rather
just get rid of the port entirely than
switch to USB type c I always wonder how
they'll address it on stage like I
imagine it'll have the little moment
where they're like how much do you
really use the charging port on your
phone and it's taking up precious space
inside the phone and hey we've had the
courage to invent this incredible new
charging technology magsafe now magsafe
magsafe is fine you know in 2022 it's
okay it doesn't fix the slow data speed
problem but it does slap onto the back
of the phone with magnets and charged at
15 watts and I think Apple's wanted
magsafe to sort of grow and evolve a
little bit faster than it has and it
kind of hasn't but now with this new
hard-coded deadline imposed by the EU
they will have the next iPhone the 2023
iPhone 15 and the next iPhone after that
the 2024 iPhone 16 to really push
magsafe before the next iPhone after the
deadline the iPhone 17.
can go portless so now it becomes very
easy to see a world where Apple stops
giving you a lightning cable with the
newest iPhones but just starts giving
everyone just the magsafe wireless
charging puck in the box and that's it
just to get people used to wireless
charging for two whole years before the
transition is just like yeah this is how
we charge all our phones now insofar as
they are capable of being recharged via
wired charging
USB type-c Oh They'll comply they'll
comply all right that was a smart reply
but yeah if it doesn't charge via wired
charging at all then they don't need a
usb-c port but the iPhone isn't the only
lightning thing that Apple makes by the
way there's some other accessories that
they make that are also on this list
Apple's magic keyboard the Magic Mouse
and airpods all also charge with
lightning right now so they will have
now also until 2024 to get that
transition going to either switch to
USBC or be portless and they've also
already kind of started that transition
you might have noticed that the new
Apple TV Siri remote charges via USBC
this year instead of lightning like it
was previously and of course the new
airpods cases all charged via lightning
but also have added magsafe compatible
wireless charging and it would feel
pretty easy for them to get rid of that
lightning port in the next two years so
the real question is will magsafe be
Advanced Enough by then for people to
not go insane will it actually because
the point is it should actually be
better than lightning for them to move
on and move forward from lightning it
should be a technological advancement
and that's actually the point and that
that gets us back to that original Spiel
that Jaws made that I skipped through
earlier because as much as it is very
much apple PR self-serving corporate
talk I actually agree with
almost
everything that he says there because
what he's saying is basically that we're
fine with the government making
regulation with a positive end goal in
mind right but they shouldn't be so
prescriptive with exactly how to do that
technologically speaking that part
should be up to the engineers and the
innovators at these companies to figure
out so if the government has a good idea
in Tech which can happen sometimes like
for example wanting hearing impaired
people to be able to use smartphones
then great fine then let the companies
actually figure out a way to make their
phones compatible with hearing aids and
then work on that Tech and make it
better over time that way everybody wins
and the tech actually improves so
because they're mandating USB type c for
all wired charging devices now it can
feel kind of like a win because
lightning kind of sucks and this is
better
but we're already kind of pushing the
envelope of USB type c that's not
exactly new either and we're getting
like 200 watt charging in smartphones
now and super high fast data speeds
eventually in a couple years we're going
to move on to something even better than
USB type c
and then what so I don't really want to
hear about the environment and E-Waste
from Apple of all people like I get that
a lot of people have lightning cables
and that's what you love about lightning
but that never stopped you from changing
all the other stuff to USB type-c so
really the behind the scenes problem is
the government being so prescriptive as
to require USB type-c instead of just
giving an overall goal like unified
charging standards to reduce e-waste and
you know maybe the the law can update
over time to keep up with the tech but
how much do you trust that to happen so
in conclusion hey I'll take a USBC
iPhone if that ends up being what
happens out of this but it's probably
not going to be what happens
um and again we'll see but it's like it
can feel like a win because USBC is
better than lightning right now
but that's just in the short term and I
think in the long term it's pretty clear
Apple's got a lot of time to think about
how they're going to get theirs
but hey when wires Wayne Wireless will
win
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]